the youtube original docu-series 30 days
with ryan garcia followed
uh ryan's journey leading up to his
fight against luke campbell which was
successful for him and it aired its
final episode
yesterday and ryan garcia the wbc
interim lightweight champion of the
world joining me here on the rich hyzer
show how are you ryan
you there ryan yes i'm here how are you
doing
how are you thanks for calling in i
appreciate it how's life for you
king ryan it's been good
um trying to uh just
uh establish things i need established
after my match
a lot of things came to me pretty quick
so i'm just uh
figuring things out all right what are
you establishing walk me through what's
life to establish for
uh for somebody who's uh got off to
a blazing wonderful career start with uh
the sky being the limit
what about that ryan um
i'm i'm establishing i guess
order in my life because when you're
giving so much
blessings and and money and fame
even more than i already had you need to
like structure things the way according
to the right way
and that's what i'm doing right now so
um
i guess you could say i'm handling my
life and i'm placing things in my life
that i need to place
does that mean uh people are coming
people are coming out of the woodwork
ryan so what you're saying
hey i want to say people are coming out
the woodworks
i mean i guess you need to you need to
know who is there to actually
support you who is there trying to
you know deceive you and uh
and and you just need to trust that
you know things will play out the way
they play on everything will be fine you
understand what i'm saying so
um it's just a lot it's a lot because a
lot has came at me so it makes sense
what do you think about um the concept
of you starting 21-0
and uh people are already mentioning the
words floyd and mayweather
in relation to the way that your record
is already started and what you can
accomplish
what do you think of when you hear that
what do i think when they mention me
again
with floyd and who who you are floyd
mayweather yeah
i just yeah floyd when you hear floyd's
name get mentioned to you what about
that
i see floyd and my name mentioned as
two opposites like kind of a mere
reflection of
myself he had it all he knew what he had
to do in the ring he had a good sense of
fighting
yet he didn't set a good example for
people
uh that look up to him and uh people who
ultimately see him as an inspiration
so honestly we're the polar opposites
i'm here to accept a good example
uh for the future generation to see me
and see that what a champion is really
about
and he's just basically somebody that
had a chance to do it and didn't do it
so how do you view your responsibilities
then that are different than what you
think floyd
has ryan walk me through that what do
you mean by that
well i'll walk i'll try to walk you
through it
um it's in my humble way
i will try to say you know because i
don't want to disrespect you you know
what i mean
okay so floyd for example right
he's gonna i'm gonna have everything
floyd had you understand what i'm saying
the money fame
women tried to come at him you know he
was what was he called
in the beginning pretty boy right what
did they call me
you know i'm saying yep but if you
really
if you if you follow floyd's journey
you know it wasn't so much his fault you
know a lot of people
didn't want to give him the credit in
the beginning
even though he was fighting everybody he
had to fight you know i'm sorry there's
people talking
it's all good ron yeah and
can you guys be quiet please
i'm sorry i'm really sorry here one
second hey
hey this is fantastic no talking i'm on
the interview
thank you interview going on that's
right ryan you said that you
you you you set the ring here man this
is this is our ring and we're
we're we're having a conversation i
appreciate that where are you right now
where are you i'm in my home
[Laughter]
fantastic oh look we're we're all we're
all quarantining best we can i
i understand it but you were saying go
for it
yeah what i was saying is um and i want
to say this in the kindest heart because
as floyd floyd so i don't know better
you know what i'm saying
um he maybe does but he chooses not to
or maybe he's just not aware and
hopefully this message reaches
to him we are almost the same
but we're not the same you know what i'm
saying so he's gonna i'm gonna have
everything he has
and more yet i'm gonna be a better
example and when i say that i mean
i'm gonna hold my values
to a standard where when people look at
me
they want they want to say wow he really
does follow god
yeah man even if he made mistakes he
still went and fixed them
you know what i'm saying and floyd and i
don't want to do this in like i'm not
trying to condemn him
and i'm not trying to judge him i'm not
trying to make him feel smaller than i
am that's not what i'm trying to do i'm
no better than him
i'm just learn faster thank god
but floyd you know he's done a lot of
things and i don't think i need to say
that
you guys could imagine i mean the past
is there
there and i'm not throwing that at his
face you know what i'm saying i'm trying
to wear this the best way i can because
i really do
i care about floyd as well but i mean i
care about everybody i love i do love
everybody
in a way
but when i say this is like
floyd had a chance to be a good example
to future generations he had a lot of
kids looking up
from the streets you know what i'm
saying from the street
you know it's one thing to come from the
streets and then it's another thing to
still
live like you're from the streets you
got blessed with everything you could
think of and you're still
you're you're still setting a horrible
example
to me that man shame on you
but that's just my opinion on it i don't
know you tell me
ryan garcia here uh on the rich eisen
show at king ryan g
on twitter at king ryan on instagram and
again 30 days with ryan garcia just
wrapped up the youtube original
docu-series
uh following ryan against luke campbell
aired the final episode just yesterday
check it out
on youtube why'd you do it why'd you
want cameras
showing your your process certainly in a
fight where
um it definitely appeared you had uh
your most uh
difficulty getting through it but you
obviously did win it knocking out luke
and
remaining undefeated why did you want
the cameras
ryan um
it was brought to me you know what i'm
saying so youtube wanted to do something
with me they were pleased with my
youtube channel
and i decided that
i decided that
i'm okay with this i'm okay to show my
flaws
i'm okay to show my vulnerability i'm
okay with
showing people that it ain't easy and
i'm
and i because you know that's the main
thing with people
that people tell lies every time like
it's easy like
like i'm sorry going back to floyd he
made he seemed like oh this is easy
i mean he did it he didn't i'm sorry he
didn't he said hard work dedication
but like i feel like with this i needed
to show
i needed to show something like
what do you say vulnerability that's the
main word i want to show vulnerability i
want to show
you know i even talked about you know
with me and my girlfriend you know at
the time i obviously
things came out and then i ended up
kissing a girl other than her and i know
i know i don't need to bring this up
right now but i feel like i have to
because that's what i showed in the
documentary it's just one example of
i'm not afraid to talk about my flaws
and i felt like i needed to do that
to people to see that you could still
become great
even if you have lost you could if you
choose to do the great things the next
time around
and i wasn't afraid i didn't care what
people say man i mean if you if you're
trying to judge me you should look at
yourself in the mirror you understand
what i'm saying
so i feel like that was what was needed
in order for me to
to i mean if i wanted a successful doc
which they brought to me i needed to be
as truthful as i can
and it'll touch people's spirit and
that's what i i plan to do with that doc
ryan garcia here on the rich eisen show
what's next for you
who's next for you what do you got for
me on that front
you know what i want i want javante
davis and i'm going to do this and maybe
a calmer manner i know what i'm going to
do
i mean when we get in the ring it's
going to take me two rounds
that is it but you know i'm also
i'm also open to if i have to if i have
to
this is if i have to fight somebody else
before that
i will do if i have to fight linares
i'll be ready
jorge linares if i have to fight him i
will
you know what i'm saying and this is the
first time i'm kind of saying another
name i still want people to know that
i will try my best to get that javante
fight first
but if for some reason either they don't
want to fight or the deal is taking too
long
i'll give a per uh the people a fight in
between i'll fight jorge linares
then why do you want manny pacquiao too
ryan
what's up i feel like he's a great
fighter you know what i'm saying so
and he's a legend and and somebody that
when you're a legend like that right
you you seen over oscar oscar passed
that torch to manny
manny manny
manny i feel like is is that it is that
inspiration that makes you a legend
eight-time world champion
he has lost but eight times weight class
world champion
i mean and and came from dirk all the
way to the
a senator in the philippines
legend that's what you call a le jin
muhammad ali oscar de la hoya
manny pacquiao and now guess what
it's my turn and i that's why i feel
like
that's why maybe after javonte hopefully
this is out of respect this is not
calling them out i don't want people to
think i'm calling him out that's so
stupid
not calling him out i'm just saying can
we share the ring together and please
pass that torch to me
well ryan garcia a couple minutes left
with uh with ryan fresh off of his uh
his victoria his victory over luke
campbell the the championship fighter
here
on the rich eisen show you just
mentioned a couple of names of guys who
fought
uh deep into their uh careers um
is it true you you intend you're 22
that uh you you've pegged 26 uh
to retire so you could uh and i'll quote
you here fight uh
against hate and confusion uh that has
been sowed in our country right now
um is that true you're gonna retire in
four years
yeah yeah i plan to a plan if i say it i
plan to do it so why
why well it goes back to the hate and
confusion part
so many lies are being said to our
country and nobody at this time knows
the truth
you get the sense of that you can't
believe anything nowadays
and that's a sad it makes me almost want
to cry
nobody is okay right now nobody has
clarity nobody has peace in their heart
nobody right now i mean some people do
the ones that know god in jesus
that's how i feel and people have to
respect that so how will you
not fighting and retiring like what do
you have that plan or
or you know what i'm saying like so many
people are
enjoying watching your your career i
mean the way that you hold yourself and
communicate is a reason why youtube
reached out to you and said let's
let's show the whole world who ryan
garcia is if you don't already know
so wouldn't your platform as a fighter
help you
do this ryan i would
you know what i enjoy that question
thank you for asking me a great question
you are welcome ryan that's what i do
for a living by the way
i'm i'm i'm a professional who uses
words and not
you know my hands but yeah i use my
hands when i talk but no
please answer go for it okay
how do i say this i plan to at 26
to retire i don't know officially right
i mean
you've seen in the past fighters have
retired came back
this is what i will say i still plan to
retire at 26.
yet yet if i
am to return back to the ring
i will only battle people that people at
that time say there's no way ryan will
beat him
that's the only time i come back and i
will always give the glory to god after
i win
that's what i plan to do all i box for
is to give the glory to god so once i
win i say thank you lord
jesus christ he's coming there it is
that's my plan
and and that i know i'm not
i'm not the king i don't i don't like
when people say right king rod you know
i mean i do like because i'm
i feel like a king in the ring like a
warrior but i like to i like to
acknowledge that
you know i live to serve jesus you know
what i mean and that's what i really
feel that
and i hope people feel that in my heart
and i don't want to push people away
you know what i'm saying i don't want
people to be like yo you just you know
somebody that just
just says that so i will show that in
the ring when it comes down to it
so to answer your question 26 i still
plan to retire
but if i do return back in the ring i
will promise everybody
that i will fight people that they say i
won't be and i'm even with you know what
i'm willing to do
sure i really haven't said this out loud
okay
what i plan to do is say say at 26 i'm
done retiring and
boxing is all good right you know what
i'll do
what if they say okay you beating
everybody in the ring right
but you know somebody goes this ain't
real fighting
you know what i mean real fighting is
legs
you know choking submission all that
guess what i'll do
i'll go prove to them that i'm the best
fighter
all around in the world i'm talking
about hands
i'm talking about wrestling i will go to
mma
to prove a point that god is greatest
and i'll go be whoever it is in mma they
say i won't be if it has to be conor
mcgregor i will and i'm not saying this
to get money i don't care about money
i'm saying this because
that's just how i feel so if that
answers your question
there it is oh that answers my question
ryan
[Laughter]
that answers my question hey god is good
okay hey ryan thanks for the time really
appreciate it
um and and if you're free later uh
things get a little out of hand around
dinner time with uh
i've got three kids can you maybe come
over and tell them to keep quiet
ryan did you do that guys hey
i think that's your job
yeah you're right you're right thanks
the time ryan um i hope this is the
first of many times you appear on this
show and we we chat
um it it really was a pleasure thank you
you asked really good questions i thank
you for having me on
you know i like being on your show so
i'm pretty sure we'll probably be on it
about
a lot more time all right ryan i look
forward to that i will hold you to that
and i look forward to uh your next
fight your next steps and uh and
congrats again on
30 days with ryan garcia which is a
youtube original docu-series that
wrapped up just
the other day thanks for coming on the
show great have a good one you got
that's uh that's
ryan garcia hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here